ก็
สวัสดีค่ะครูเอ๋
ต้องเอาอย่าผิวคือต้องก็ต้องสวัสดีค่ะนัก
เรียน
นักเรียนทุกคนค่ะ
เอ๋สบายดีไหมคะสบายดีทุกคลิปเลยค่ะ
สบายดีแข็งแรง
นะคะสบายดีไหมคะ
นักเรียนสบายดีคอมเม้นนะคะสบายดีครับครู
สบายดีค่ะครูนะคะ
กูต้องคลิปคลิปนี้ไม่เอาวันละไม่ต้องไม่
ต้องวันหลังไม่เอามันมาคุยกันเลยดีกว่านะ
คะคุณต้องอยู่นิ่งๆใช่ไหมต้องจะได้ไม่
เบลอตายกล้องจะโฟกัสกูเองนะกู a อยู่นิ่ง
ๆมี
กูตั้มคู๋
อะไรนะได้ยินบอกคุณต้องอยากคุยอากูเอณวัน
นี้วันอาทิตย์ครูต้องก็ได้พักผ่อนนอน
ก็ไม่ต้องทำอะไร
นะคู๋ต้องทำอะไรบ้าง
นอนวันนี้กูต้องกินข้าวไหมกินข้าว
อ่ะล้างจานไหมร้านจานไม่ต้องค่ะไม่ต้อง
ล้างจาน
Google ไหมคะไม่ต้องทำอาหารไหมค่ะนิด
หน่อยซักผ้าไหมคะวิพากษ์ซักไม่สักค่ะน้อง
เรียนเข้าใจสักผ้าไหมครับกูอีกซักมือมี
ผ้าสีผ้ารักซัก
เอกวาดรูปดีกว่าตัวเองวาดรูป
อ้าว
โอเคเอามาๆมี
โอเคถ้าเป็นนักเรียนก็จะมีตัวเรือนสังคา
ค่ะองค์กลมๆแล้วก็เอาเสื้อ
กางเกง
ใส่เข้าไปแล้วก็กด
โอ้ยก่อนลืมเสียบปลั๊ก
เสียบปลั๊ก
เราก็ใส่ข้อน้ำยาใส่น้ำยาอ้าใส่น้ำยาซัก
ผ้ามาใส่บีใส่ attack แล้วก็กดแล้ว
เครื่องเช็คผ้าก็หมุน R
ตาลอันนี้แบบนักเรียนท่าแบบครูเอ๋เนี่ยก็
คือมีกาละมัง
โอ้โห
แล้วก็มีน้ำแล้วก็ใส่น้ำยาใช่ไหมคะน้ำยา
เป็นขวดอ่ะกันคุยก็เป็นขวดนี่แหละใส่รอง
ไปแล้วก็เอาเสื้อใส่เสื้อใส่กางเกงใส่
แล้วก็สัตว์
หงอของเขาเรียกว่าซักมือนะรู้จักมือถือ
อ่าหมดต้องซักไหมคะไม่ซักผ้า
ไม่ทำอะไรไม่ทำอาหารทำอาหารนิดหน่อยอ่า
นิดหน่อยไม่นั้นจานซักผ้า
มาย
ไม่ถูบ้านไม่แปรงฟัน
รีดผ้ามีภาพไว้ไม่มีรีดผ้าต้องมีเตารีดนะ
คะนักเรียนคือเหมือนไหมคะพร้อม
แล้วก็มีเสื้อที่นี่ค่ะ
รีบพา
ถ้าไหมคะไม่รีบค่ะอุ้ยกูต้องทำอะไรคะวัน
นี้วันนี้คุณต้อมนอนค่ะแล้วก็เล่น
โทรศัพท์ค่ะ
แม่ไม่สบายบ้างมากเดี๋ยวๆแล้วใครซักผ้า
ใครรีดผ้าใครล้างจานคุณคุณครูครูต้องมี
แจ๋วอยู่ที่บ้านเหรอคะ
ไม่มีคนนี้มี
มิตรแบบไฮโซว่ามีเงินเดือนได้แจ๋วล้างจาน
ซักผ้ารีดผ้า
ปูต้มไม่ไฮโซคุณต้อมไม่มีแต่เขา
ไม่มีงั้นโอ๊ยกินแล้วโยนจานทิ้งล่ะคะมี
จานข้าวเนี่ย
จานข้าวกินแล้วไม่ล้างทิ้งหรอคะไม่ทิ้ง
ค่ะกินระวังไว้
ใครล้าง
สามีค่ะ
หือ
ถ้ามีล้างจานโอเคใครซักผ้า
โอ้นี่
สามีซักผ้าถ้าใครรีดผ้า
3 มี่
ขอดูหน้าตามีหน่อย
คุณไปหาที่ไหนคุณต้องไปหานี่น่ารักมากค่ะ
อันนี้กูต้อมราคาคุณต้อมแต่งงานถ้าภาษา
การนี้กูต้องผมยาวได้ยาวนิสามีนะคะอันนี้
กูต้อม
สามีครูต้อมรีดผ้า
มองสามีครูต้อมซักผ้าพักพ่อตามีครูต้อม
ล้างจานคะใช่ค่ะอาหารได้ไหมทำอาหารได้นิด
หน่อยถูบ้านถูบ้านไม่ค่อยถูกขี้เกียจน้อ
แต่แต่ซักผ้าซักผ้าโอเคจ้าโอเคดีมากรีบ
ภาพเก่งมากครูต้องสามีคุณต้องมีพี่ชาย
หรือน้องชายเนี่ยฮะ
ไม่มีแล้วค่ะมีอะไรคะ
ปู AV แล้ว
ที่บ้านไม่ซับสักผ้าไม่เป็น
รีบภาพไม่เป็น
ร้านชาญ
ยังไงคะใช้เวลา 1 ชั่วโมง
ร้านจานนะล้างจานอ่ะ 10 ใบจานเนี่ย 10 ใบ
หนึ่งชั่วโมง
ฮะโอเคไม่เห็ดมากไม่เสร็จกูอ่ะบอกหยุดไม่
ต้องล้างไม่ต้องล้างคุยล้างเองอุ้ยกู a3e
ครูต้อมล้างจาน
รู้มากกู
ดีมากดีมากแต่เดี๋ยวครูต้อม
ที่บ้านสามีมีหน้าที่ล้างจานเหรอคะใช่ค่ะ
ถ้ามีเป็นคนไทยนะคะตามมีเป็นคนไทยค่ะ
[เพลง]
แต่คนไทยอ่ะ
ตึกคือคุณไทยรุ่นนี้ไม่รู้จะคนไทยรุ่นกู
ต้อมรุ่นคู่ a เนี่ย
มันกูเองอ่ะพ่อแม่บอกนะถ้าเพิ่ม
ห้ามห้ามห้ามห้ามนะคะ
ห้ามสามี
นี้นะคะสามีนะผู้ชายน่ะอ้ะสัตว์ฆ่าผู้
หญิง
ใช่ห้ามสามีรีดผ้า
ช้างๆๆ
จานอะนี่งานผู้หญิง
ไม่ไหวไปค่ะแล้วคุณต้องให้สามีทำฝามีครู
ต้องเป็นพ่อบ้านชอบทำงานบ้างงานของเขาก็
คือทำงานบ้านค่ะแต่ครูต้อมออกไปทำงานข้าง
นอกบ้านเอาสลับกันออกเป็นแบบนิ้วกับสมัย
ใหม่ให้ข้าโอเคไหม
โอเคมาก
หนีมาอ่า
17 ปีแล้วค่ะ
เยี่ยมๆมา
เรียมปลาสลับหน้าที่กันใช่ไหมคะไอ้ขาด
สลับกันที่
แล้วกู a พูดถึงคนไทยเมื่อก่อนจะไม่ให้
ผู้ชายซักผ้ารีดผ้าใช่ไหมคะใช่มากได้เห
มือใหม่เพราะอะไร
[เพลง]
รู้แต่เรื่องยาวกูเองเล่าได้มั้ง
ต้องคิดว่าอ่าต้องคิดว่าอะไรมึงต้องคิด
ว่าผู้ชาย
รีดผ้าซักผ้าจะไม่ดีคนไทยคิดว่าไม่ดีจะ
ไม่มี
ไม่ดีค่ะไม่ดีจะไม่เจริญ
ถ่ายใช่มั้ยใช่ก็ไม่รู้ทำไมเพราะสมัยก่อน
เป็นอย่างนี้นักเรียนคะสมัยก่อนเนี่ยคน
ไทยเรามีความเชื่อน้องมีความเชื่อว่าอ่ะ
มีอะไรที่โชคดีแล้วก็โชคไม่ดีผู้ชายเนี่ย
จะเป็นพระ
พระใช่ไหมคะอ่ะนักเรียนรู้จักพระไม่
โอเค
พระ
ค่ะพระก็จะใส่ชุดสีส้มๆนะคะ
สีเหลืองแล้วบอกสีเหลืองสีเหลืองเป็นพระ
พระอยู่ที่ไหนครับคุณต้องเพราะก็จะอยู่
ที่วัดท่าเก๋
ไม่มาพระจะอะวัดศรี
วัดสีส้มไปแล้วอยู่ที่วัดนะคะมีของแต่ง
ที่นี้น่ะเวลาเป็นพระใช่ไหมคะนักเรียน
หรือบางคนเนี่ยก็จะมีนอกจากเป็นพระแล้ว
เขาก็จะมีสร้อยคอที่เป็นพระลาแล้วก็เสื้อ
ผ้าผู้หญิงอ่ะเขาบอกว่าเสื้อผ้าเป็นความ
เชื่อบอกเสื้อผ้าผู้หญิงสกปรกนะคะคำว่า
สกปรกอย่างเช่นถ้าถ้าโต๊ะและมี
โต๊ะเหนอ่ะสกปรกหรือที่วัดวัดมีต้นไม้
จะได้คะมีใบไม้หล่นลงมาอ่ะอันเนี้ยหรือมี
นกนก
นกนกที่ลงมา
นกขี้ก็สกปรก
ค่ะเขาก็จะคิดว่าเสื้อผ้าผู้หญิงน่ะศพกับ
ปรกมากผู้ชายนะ
คะอันนี้อันนี้คิดนะคะอ่าเนื่องจากผู้ชาย
เนี่ยเป็นพระหรือเป็นอะไรก็จะมีน้ำโมตาสะ
ภัคคะวะโตอะระมีสวดมนต์มีนะคะเป็นมนต์
สำหรับผู้ชายที่ผู้หญิงน่ะไปโดนไม่ได้
อย่างนี้ค่ะงั้นเนี่ยการที่ให้ผู้ชายมา
ซักซักเสื้อผ้าผู้หญิงซึ่งซึ่งถ้าเป็น
เสื้ออาจจะโอเคแบบถ้าเป็นกระโปรง
เป็นชุดชั้นใน
อย่างนี้ค่ะชุดชั้นในวันนี้ที่บ้านกูอีก
ถือมากๆนะคะไม่ได้เลยค่ะไม่ได้ไม่ได้จี้
คุณป้าคุณป้าๆป้าอีกแล้วก็มาอีกแล้วปลามา
อีกแล้วคุณป้าพูดเร็วหรือเปล่าคะนัก
เรียนคุณป้าก็คือขอขอบคุณคุณพระพระเชิญ
พระออกก่อนนะคะค่ะนกออกดีกว่า
คุยกับนกออกสำนักกดต้อมค่ะ
เว็บ
โอเค
อา
ไม่มีแต่รู้จักครอบครัวอีกเยอะๆแล้วเนี่ย
สอนกับครูต้อมนี้นักเรียนจะรู้จัก
ครอบครัวเยอะเลยอ่ะ
นะคะอันนี้เอ๋นะคะเอ๋
พี่ชอบสาวพี่ชายน้องชายน้องใช่อะไรก็ได้
เอ้าชายเอกก็ศักดิ์ค่าถูบ้านทำอาหาร
ไม่ทำการนะคะเพราะว่าแต่งงานแล้วก็ภรรยา
เนี่ยไปทำงานไปค่ะขายอาหารน้องใช้ดูแลบ้า
มีทั้งบนหน้า
ส่วนอะคุณป้าเอ๋น่ะคุณป้าเอ๋ละคนไทยบอก
หัวนะโบราณคิดต่อถ้าพี่ชายเอ๋ก็หัวโบราณ
หัวโบราณก็คือผู้ชายจะไม่จับเสื้อผ้าผู้
หญิง
Who ไม่ได้เขาเหมือนกับมีมีอะไรไม่รู้
อ้าถ้าจับแล้วเนี่ยจะโชคไม่ดี
ร้องงานก็ไม่ก้าวหน้าค่ะอันนี้เค้าคิดงาน
ก็ไม่ดีชีวิตก็อาจจะมีผีมาอะไรอ๋ออ๋อค่ะ
อันนี้อันนี้พี่ชายคิดแต่คุณป้าเนี่ยคุณ
ป้าก็บอกว่า
ผู้หญิงเนี่ยถ้ามีผู้ชายซักค่าให้
ก็โชคไม่ดี
จะไม่ดีไม่ทำงานก็ไม่ก้าวหน้า
ก็ไม่ก้าวหน้าอันนี้มาพูดคุณป้าก็บอกเห
ศักดิ์ผ้าเก๋ทำอาหารเหกุบ้านเหล้างจารย์
เอ๋ไปออฟฟิศดู
Ed ทุกๆอย่างฉันเหนื่อยวะมาก
ครูเอกกลัวอะไรรู้ไหมกูเอ๋น่ากลัวว่าถ้า
แต่งงาน
แล้วมีลูกแล้วสามีเนี่ยมีพ่อมีแม่มีมีมี
มีพี่มีน้อง
ซัก 10 คนอย่างเนี้ยโอ้โห
ถ้า
ทุกคน
ถ้าทุกคนของทุกคนทำอาหารสำหรับทุกคน
อยู่ไหนแต่งงานกับครอบครัวนะเอกแต่งงานดี
กว่าเจดูอยู่คนเดียวไม่กล้าแต่งงานกับคน
ไทยใครนี้
รวมว่า
และสบายแต่งงานกับคนต่างประเทศน่ะห่า
คือโดนบอกว่าต้องทำต้องทำต้องทำมาอ่ะกูก็
บอกว่าจะโชคไม่ดีถ้าให้สามีค่ะนะคะวิ่ง
ตัวนะคนต้อมผ่ากลัวแล้วก็เลยไม่แต่งงาน
แต่พอแต่คิดว่าแต่งงานกับคนไทยไม่ได้พ่อ
แม่สามีแต่โกรธถ้าคุยบอกสามีซักผ้าเมื่อ
อาแปะมีซักผ้าหน่อยอันนี้ปลามีไว้ยังไง
แม่จะโกรธใช่ป่ะเอออ๋อ
ไม่คุยคิดคนคิดคุณแม่กูเอกก็บอกคุณแม่คุณ
แม่กูเองอ่ะตอนคุณแม่ท้องคุยเอาอันนี้ออก
อ่ะ
คุณแม่ท้องอ่อนขอเชิญพระออกนะคะในมนต์ค่ะ
คุณแม่ท้องรึ
กูแม่ท้องน่ะ
ข้อเอ๋น่ารักนะ
พ่อเอ๋น่ะซักผ้า
เพราะว่าแม่ต้องนอน
นอนที่นี่น่ะ 1 เดือน
กูแม่มีไฟตรงนี้นะคะก็นึกว่าอยู่ไฟอยู่ไฟ
มีไฟที่นี่ให้ร้อนๆเวลาร่อนเรียนคะท้องค
ลอดลูกปั๊ปเนี่ยคนไทยจะอยู่ไฟก็คือมีไฟ
ค่ะก็คือให้แม่ร้อนๆมาที่นี่ร้อนนอนไม่มี
ไฟนะเค้าใส่อะไรอีกคู๋มันอกสาวหน้าเลยอ่ะ
อ้าอะไรบางคนที่ก็ใส่สมุนไพรอะไรไม่รู้นิ
ใครอ่ะให้ร้อนๆนะคะที่เนี่ย 30 วันบางคน 3
เดือนใช่ไหมค่ะ
ถึงถึงเก้าสิบวัน
คุณแม่กูเอ๋อ่ะคุณพ่อไม่ไม่ไม่รวยก็ 30
วันอบ
คือทำให้อยู่ไฟไม่แข็งแรงจะหนาวน่าจะหนาว
คนไทยแบบต้องอยู่ไฟอยู่ไฟแล้วอ้าไม่หนาว
อาจจะแข็งแรงน่าจะแข็งแรงมากก็นอนเนี่ย 30
วันแม่คุณพ่อทำอาหาร
ซักผ้าคุณพ่อล้างจานคุณพ่อทำทั้งหมดเลย
กูกรรมไปเกิดอะไรขึ้นไงคะ
ที่บ้านใช่มะบ้าน
มีบ้านอื่น
บ้านอื่นทำไมคะมีคนเดินมาเห็นเห็นอ้อครู
เอ๋ซักผ้า
กอล์ฟไปพูดนี่ภรรยาบ้านนั้นไม่ดีให้สามี
ซักผ้าขอ
[เพลง]
สามีจะโชคไม่ดีไม่มีเจริญเจริญคือนี้จะ
ไม่รวยจะโชคไม่ดีไม่ดีไม่ดีขอให้ภรรยาไม่
ดี
อ๋อก็พูดๆดังๆเลยตัวอย่างดังๆ
ชายแม่ได้ยิน
คุณแม่ว่ายังไงเสียใจแม่เราให้ขอเสียใจ
บุญพ่อได้ยิน
คุณเพราะโกรธ
พ่อบอกผมผู้ชายดี
คุณพ่อเยี่ยมมากค่ะก็อยู่กันสองคนสองคน
ใช่ไหมคะภรรยาคลอดลูกเจ็บเดินไม่ได้
อีกก็ซักผ้าโอเค
คายไม่ไม่เป็นไรแต่ป้าบอกไม่โอเคป่า Who
ไม่ได้คุณพ่อบอกได้
ให้คุณป้ามาช่วยนะฮะได้มั้ยคะใช่ๆกุนาสัก
อ๋อ
ถ้าคุณป้ามาคุณป้าซักคะ
เพราะว่าถ้าป้าไม่มาก็คุณพ่อซักเค้าซัก
ผ้าเยี่ยวก็ไม่ดีนะคะแล้วก็ต้องมีคนพูด
อะไรไหมของครูต้อมตอนนี้ไม่พูดอะไรแต่
สมัยก่อนอ่ะกูต้องคิดว่าผู้ชายกับผู้หญิง
อ่ะไม่เท่ากันไม่เท่ากันน่ะกูเองผู้ชาย
สักเยี่ยมผู้ชายดีกว่าผู้หญิงผู้หญิงดี
เหมือนกันแต่ดีนิดนึงผู้ชายดีกว่าแต่ตอน
เนี้ยผู้ชายก็ดีผู้หญิงก็ดีเท่ากันเท่า
กันสมัยก่อนที่เมืองไทยอ่ะอย่างคุณต้อง
บอกกูต้องไปทำงานสามีเป็นบ้านถ้าถ้าเป็น
เมื่อก่อนนี้น่ะโอ้โหผู้ชายต้องอดทนมากๆ
หมอเขาจะมีซุบซิบๆตำๆดูบ้านนั้นดิผู้ชาย
ขี้เกียจไม่ทำงานให้ภรรยาทำคนเดียว
กูเอกก็มีเพื่อนที่เป็นแบบนี้นะเขาทำสื่อ
แต่ว่าภรรยาเงินเดือนมากกว่าไงใช่มากกว่า
รักสามีก็ทำอาหารอร่อย
ชายหมดก่อนผู้ชาย
ออกไปทำงานแต่ผู้หญิงต้องอยู่บ้าน
ห้ามทำงานห้ามออกไปข้างนอกผู้หญิงไทยต้อง
อยู่บ้านนั้นว่าประมาณ 100 ปีที่แล้วกู
ต้อง
อยู่บ้าน 100 เมตรแล้วแต่ตอนนี้ล่ะตอนนี้
เอากันแล้วค่ะ
แล้วคุณต้องมีปัญหาหมายถึงว่ามีคนพูดอะไร
ไหมที่สามีอยู่บ้านกูต้องไปทำงานบ่มีพระ
คุณต่อมีอยากคุยอันนี้กูอีกก็เลยสงสัยชาย
มีคนพูดว่า
ซักผ้าให้เมียเจริญ
ออกไม่บอกว่าไม่ดีไม่ดีออกว่าดีเจริญดี
มากเชื่อฟังเมียพูดแล้วก็ฟังเมียพูดแล้ว
ก็ฟังแล้วก็คิดแล้วก็เชื่อเมียเจริญค่ะ
ครูเอ๋เปลี่ยนแล้วใช่ไหมไม่เหมือนว่าก่อน
เปลี่ยนหมดแล้วค่ะ
[เพลง]
เข้าใจเข้าใจ
หากมีเลยของครูเอ๋คะครูเอ๋คุณสามีทำงาน
ข้างนอกใช่ไหมคะเค้า a เป็น
สามีเป็นคนญี่ปุ่นเนาะ
เหมือนคนไทยโบราณเนาะอ๋อ
กูเอกคิดว่าถ้าไม่เอาไม่อยากอยู่บ้านไม่
อยากซักผ้าไม่อยากทำงานบ้านมะม่วงขึ้น
แต่งงาน Pop โอเคคุณป้าสอนไว้ 100% อยู่
ที่นี่ซักผ้าทำอาหารรีดผ้าอยู่บ้านหยุด
ที่ทำ
อ๋อ
เนี่ยวิ่งชอบแม่ทำงานบ้านไม่ใช่ชอบคือ
ต้องไม่ได้ชอบแต่ว่ามันอยู่ที่หัว
ที่บ้านสอนสอนผู้หญิงซักผ้าผู้หญิงรีดผ้า
ผู้หญิงทำอาหารผู้หญิง
ถูบ้านก็เลยมันอยู่ในหัวพอแต่งงานจริงๆก็
ก็ทำเป็น automatic
โดยอัตโนมัตินะคะแต่ a โชคดี
โชคดียังไงยังไงกิน
และก็ได้อ๋อ
ทำอะไรก็กินแล้วก็ถ้าครูเอ๋เอ๋ทำบ้านไม่
สะอาดสามีก็ไม่เป็นไรโอ้ยดีจังค่าอะไรนะ
ทำอาหารไม่อร่อยก็ไม่เป็นไร
อาสากค่ะเหนื่อยก็โทรศัพท์อ่ะมาเอาผ้าไป
แล้วซักอันนี้โอเคอ๋อ
แล้วคู่เอ๋เอ๋ก็ชอบออกไปทำงานนอกบ้านด้วย
ใช่ไหมคะใช่แต่สรุปไม่ดีซักผ้าเองหรอ
สักมือน้อทำไมไม่ซักเที่ยงเครื่องซักผ้า
เนื้อผ้ามันเหม็นนะหรอใช่กูเองใส่น้ำยา
เยอะๆ
กูกูเองก็เจ็บจมูกให้เหม็นอีก
จังเลยค่ะเบอร์ดีที่สุดสักมือทุ่มวันออก
กำลังกาย
[เพลง]
กล้าม
ตาย
ตามซักผ้าสุดยอดค่ะและภรรยาจะตอนนี้จะมี
คนเอกกะซักผ้าค่ะเพราะว่ากูไอ้สัตว์มือ
คือสามีก็บอกแค่ 1 วัน 1 ตัวสามีจะซัก
เสื้อตัวเองเสื้อทำยังไงล่ะรักยังไงนะใส่
น้ำยาเยอะๆว่า
อ๋อน้ำยา 1 ขวดนะคะนะคะนี้น้ำแต่น้ำยาซัก
ผ้า 1 สามีใส่เท่าเนี่ยค่ะโห
สองครั้งหมด
ใช่หมดเลยค่ะบางทีใส่เครื่องซักผ้าเก๋
ซื้อน้ำยามาแล้วก็ใส่มีเสื้อผ้า 10 ตัว
และเมื่อก่อนนะว่าก่อนเมื่อก่อนใช้
เครื่องซักผ้าสามีก็เทปุ๊บเอกน้ำยาหายไป
ไหนหนู
10 ตัวใส่น้ำยาเยอะมากหนู
หยุดไม่ต้องซักผ้าคู๋ซอง
B แล้วค่ะ
ก็ก็ไม่เป็นไรค่ะจริงๆบ้านกูเอกก็เหมือน
แค่ๆบ้านกูต้องสามีซักได้แต่สามีขวิดทำ
ไม่เป็นอ๋อ
เพราะว่าบ้านเขาให้บ้านเขาไม่เคยทำแต่คุณ
พ่อทำนะถ้าใช่ครูต้องก็ไม่ชอบทำงานบ้าน
ไม่ชอบรีดผ้าแต่ครูต้อมชอบออกไปทำงานข้าง
นอกมันสนุกสนุกแฮปปี้มากแต่คุณต้องไม่มี
ใครไม่มีใครพูดใช่ไหมทำไมให้สามีซักผ้ามี
คนพูดถ้ามีคนพูดนิดหน่อยเพราะเขาเห็นกู
ต้องเหนื่อยทำไมไม่ให้สามีออกไปทำงานข้าง
นอกหาเงินมาเยอะๆกูต้องบอกว่าไม่เอาเพราะ
ว่าที่บ้านมีลูก
สามีต้องกลับลูกอาบน้ำอาบน้ำแปรงฟันใช่
ข้าวเลี้ยงลูกเหนื่อยว่าให้แล้วก็แต่งตัว
ใส่เสื้อผ้า I โรงเรียนขับรถไปส่งลูกตั้ง
แต่
6:00 นเพราะกูต้องต้องไปทำงานผู้ต้อมไม่
ไหวเหนื่อยมาก
ก็เลยเปลี่ยนหน้าที่เก่งกันเออดูรูปหนู
ต้องไปทำงานก่อนนะบ๊ายบาย
ปัจจุบันโอเคนะคะผู้หญิงน้ำผู้ชายอยู่
บ้านโอเคถ้ามาแล้วก่อนไม่ได้ผู้หญิงต้อง
อยู่บ้านผู้ชายทำงานคือหรือว่าสองคนไปทำ
งาน 2 คนกลับมาช่วยกันก็โอเคนะคะท่อนค่ะ
อะไรก็ได้ตอนนี้อะไรก็ได้แต่บ้านเขาไม่
เอาบ้านกูเองยังเป็นเหมือนเมื่อก่อนผู้
หญิงทำอ๋อไม่มีนะคะบ้านนี้บ้านนี้บ้าบ้าน
นี้ผู้หญิงทำเก่าแต่ว่าไม่ทำก็ได้
ทำก็ได้ไม่ทำก็ได้
คุณต้องเคยอ่านหนังสือหรือที่ต่างประเทศ
ก็มีแบบนี้ที่สลับกันเยอะหลายๆบ้านค่ะ
แล้วแต่บ้านเนาะไม่ได้นะไม่มีผิด
และแต่คนไทยบางคนก็ยังคิดไม่ดีแต่หรั่งดี
คดีความสุขแฮปปี้ทั้งคู่ดีๆแบบก็ต้องอดทน
นะผู้ชายที่อยู่บ้านก็ต้องอดทนถ้ามีใคร
พูดใช่มั้ยอะไรอย่างนี้บ้างนะคะ
เขาก็แฮปปี้นะครูเอ๋มีตังค์กับตังให้
กำลังใจสามีกำลังใจ
เดี๋ยวเขาเหนื่อยเขาก็นอนค่ะนอนแล้วก็
เล่นเกมๆๆ
จริงๆเขาทำงานที่บ้านก็ได้ใช่มะ
work  from  home ของแท้
โอเคค่ะคลิปนี้แล้วใช่ไหมกูต้มหมดเวลาใช่
ใช่ค่ะ
บ้านนักเรียนราคาใครทำงานบ้าน
ไทยโบราณ
ไทยจีนโบราณผู้หญิงนะคะปัจจุบัน 50  50
หรือหญิงคะนอกผู้ชายที่บ้านโอเคนะคะอ่ะก็
ประมาณ 60 เปอร์เซ็นต์นะ 60% ยังผู้หญิง
ทำงานบ้านนะคะ
โอเคค่ะงั้นคลิปนี่เราไปกันเถอะเราไปกัน
เถอะพักผ่อนเถอะให้เดี๋ยวเราค่อยมาคุยกัน
ใหม่นะคะครูเอ๋บ๊ายบายค่ะนักเรียนไม่บ้าง
นักเรียนขอบคุณค่ะครู a สวัสดีค่ะอ่ะ